- N'importe quand,
je suis prête.
- Passer un dernier Noël avec
sa famille, c'est le souhait
le plus cher d'Anne LeBlanc,
76 ans. Cette semaine, elle aape
était trop avancé pour continuer
les traitements.
la chirurgie visui
retirer une tumeur a été annulée
à la dernière minute, alors
qu'elle était en route vers
le bloc opératoire.
Elle a été placée sur une liste
d'attente prioritaire, mais
on ne l'a jamais rappelée.
ANNE LEBLANC,
atteinte d'un cancer du foie
- Je me compte très, très
chanceuse d'être capable d'avoir
vécu jusqu'à ce temps-là.
- Anne LeBlanc aborde la
situation avec une certaine
sérénité, mais szanne,
elle, est furieuse. Elle accuse
le gouvernement de Jason Kenney
d'être responsable de
l'engorgement du système de
santé albertain.
SUZANNE MARNEY,
fille d'Anne LeBlanc
- C'est lui qui a décidé de ne
pas accepter l'aide, quand les
autres provinces ont dit : "Hé!
On peut venir aider!" Et lui, il
a dit: "Ah non! On est bon."
- Cet été, le gouvernement
albertain a levé toutes les
restrictions sanitaires dans la
province, ce qui a mené à une
explosion de cas de COVID-19,
à l'automne. Selon le ministère
de la Santé, au moins
15 000 chirurgies ont été
reportées pour laisser des lits
aux malades de la COVID-19
lors de la 4e vague. Au total,
plus de 81 000 chirurgies sont
en attente.
Cette experte a étudié l'impact
du délestage sur les patients.
Selon elle, le report des
chirurgies a d'importantes
conséquences sur leur santé
mentale et leur qualité de vie.
De son côté, Anne LeBlanc ne
sait pas combien de temps de
plus la chirurgie lui aurait
permis de vivre, mais elle
assure qu'elle n'a aucun regret.
- Je v les cadeaux
avec les enfants, on va rire,
on va avoir du plaisir.
Je vais boire mon "Baileys
coffee" et ça va bien aller.
- Ici Andréane Williams,
Radio-Canada, B